-Every time we have you on, we
always make you do fun things.
But you're always game.
You're the best.
That's why we love you.
-Thank you.
And I'm just terrified
the entire time.
-Well, you're a great singer.
We know that.
But you're also
a great impressionist.
We had you on and played
Wheel of Impressions,
musical impressions,
and you crushed it both times.
So tonight I thought
I wanted to challenge you
with something bigger, okay?
I really want to challenge you
with something fun.
Now, here's --
Here's what I'm going to do.
I want you to start
singing one song, okay?
But when the name changes
on the screen right there,
you have to change to your
impression of that singer.
-Okay.
-But keep the same song.
-Oh, gosh. [ Laughs ]
-I don't know why I keep
asking you to do this stuff.
That's so cruel, but the
audience will love it, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, come on. Come on.
-All right.
-So, the song that you'll be
singing tonight is "Bad Guy."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Only the hardest song
to do impressions...
-All right. When you see
the name, you be that person.
-Should I stand?
What am I doing?
Should I take it up a notch?
-You wanna take it up a notch?
-Or maybe shouldn't.
-Yeah, take it up a notch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do I stand, too?
Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter.
-Maybe I'll get up
halfway through.
halfway through. No guarantees.
Could be sitting.
Could be standing.
I don't want to get
anyone hyped up. Yeah.
-I'm gonna surprise you guys.
We'll see what happens.
-Roots, do you have
the "Bad Guy" beat?
Can you give us something?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ White shirt now red,
my bloody nose ♪
♪ Sleeping,
you're on your tippy toes ♪
♪ Creepin' around
like nobody knows ♪
♪ Think you're so criminal ♪
♪ Bruises on both my knees
for you ♪
♪ Don't say "thank you"
or "please" ♪
♪ I do what I want
when I'm wantin' to ♪
♪ My soul? So cynical ♪
♪ You're a tough guy ♪
♪ "Like it really rough" guy ♪
♪ "Chest always so puffed" guy ♪
♪ I'm that bad type ♪
♪ "Make your mama sad" type ♪
♪ "Might seduce your dad" type ♪
♪ I'm the bad guy ♪
♪ "Make your mama sad" type ♪
♪ Make your girlfriend
mad-tight ♪
♪ Might seduce your dad ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I'm the bad guy ♪
♪ Duh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohh! Come on, now! That's
how you do it right there.
Alessia Cara!